hey what's up my name is samuel lees i'm
just sat with raja now raja
is a very successful property
entrepreneur
he literally has built up his whole
portfolio
doing phenomenally well off the back of
watching my videos
so i'm going to interview him he's doing
social housing rent to rent he's done
some sales
very very very profitable deals so you
want to listen
you want to take notes in joy roger
great to have you with me in the studio
how's it going hi samuel thanks for
having me on really appreciate it
um really really good actually
surprisingly even though we're going
through a pandemic right now
and still managing to smash it and um
carry on with deals
and this is the very first time we've
physically met yeah because you've done
all of the training online
yeah so respect that's the crazy thing i
mean like literally youtube is a
powerful thing right
yeah you went down the rabbit hole of
youtube tell me how
you got into property how that came
about right at the end stages
yes so it's been a couple of years since
i've been interested in property and the
interest really sparked from
your youtube channel um so i was at
university
um as you do whilst you're revising
you're just watching videos in the
background
and one of the ones that came up on the
side as a thumbnail was one of your uh
videos
and i had a listen through and i was
like wow okay this sounds really
interesting like there's a lot of other
strategies that i hadn't heard of like
rent to rent and lease options
um so yeah let me do a bit more research
into this and then obviously you release
content quite regularly so
it kind of spiraled from there like
listening to every episode and kind of
thinking
well if samuel can do it and you have
your winners on wednesday as well and
if all these other people can do it why
can't i yeah and so yeah i just made
like loads of notes off of the back of
it
and built up a bit of networking over
the past couple of years as well before
i got started
and at the time as well i hope you don't
mind saying this yeah you were
considering coming down to a crash
course or not yes
you were strongly advised not to go yeah
what happened so it was really annoying
and frustrating now looking back at it
because
like i said i've been networking with a
few different people and been to a
couple of events
um and these were paid events as well
like they're like they weren't even free
events they were paid events
and people like i spoke about like going
on training and stuff like that people
said
don't go to any training don't go into
any crash courses um
like it's just a sales pitch kind of
thing and now i look back at it i really
regret not going on those courses
because i think i could have got number
one a lot of value from the course
number two a lot more value from the
network and like the people that were at
the events as well
yeah yeah and it's interesting because i
mean i know you've done ridiculously
well
um as it is but it kind of didn't start
until
like february march time when you really
started doing it which is when
yeah we're going to start and we closed
down all our courses by the way so i
know we've been doing videos and online
stuff um but um but anyway forget with
all the bad stuff maybe you could have
got there faster and whatnot
but hey over the last six months you've
done some crazy
crazy things your first deal didn't go
too well no
it didn't so um i'll talk you a little
bit through that so
basically i and this was completely off
market
i managed to source a property through
gumtree um and i went and viewed the
property it looked amazing the landlord
just refurbished it
um however for my strategy because i
specifically focus on social housing
supported living
and i had to kind of get it to the hmo
regulation so
fire doors you know strips and all that
sort of stuff um
because we just come into the pandemic i
couldn't get a contractor out to come
and
like complete on the property so i
probably had that property for about
four weeks before i kind of had to say
to the landlord
i'm really sorry but i'm gonna have to
hand this back i can't move forwards
with it but i was quite lucky in the
fact that
the landlord was happy to give me that
kind of as a rent-free period anyway
right um so i hadn't like eaten to any
profits or anything like that and the
landlord was very understanding like it
was more time wasted
yeah exactly like and he knew obviously
it's a pandemic it's difficult to get
people out as well so unfortunately i
had to hand that deal back
yeah it happens though in fact that i
was just sat with a guy um
last week yeah um called nigel and he's
done really well similar to yourself
some really well
with rent to rent his first deal was
atrocious it didn't work out and i think
again the difference between winners and
losers the reason you're on winners
wednesday and not losers tuesday
yeah we don't have that we don't have
that thankfully but but i could do i'm
sure i could equally as find as many
people that have tried and failed
but the reason the difference between
the two is that winners
fail but continue yep losers fail and
give up
exactly everybody fails and you have to
fail your way into success
so i'm glad that you i'm glad that you
failed and i'm glad that you publicly
talked about it
yes yes because um you know most people
would have given up at that point so
pandemic deal fails hand back the keys
load of wasted time maybe a little bit
of money even when she does well then
what happens
yeah so at that point um i was like well
i've kind of learned from this first
deal that i probably need to have a
power team in place instead of just kind
of reaching out to people on the go
um so i spent a little bit of time
contacting people getting contacts in my
book
um found a great couple of contractors
um and then at that point i was like
right i'm gonna go back out again
and you know make an attempt number two
um and at this point
because i built up a bit more of a
network i started speaking with sourcing
agents as well
um so i had a great chat his name is
ronaldo he helped me source another
property
um and that was through an estate agents
and basically we took that on and
because i already had the people in
place we managed to get the work done
pretty quickly
like literally over a few days i think
to get that set up
um it costs me two and a half grand for
the sourcing fees
yeah uh about 2 800 for
the um like slight refurb and hmo work
so like really really cheap
really easy to get into like everything
under 5k
and that property i've still got it um
even though you know we're in a second
lockdown everything's still going really
well
off the back of that uh making 650 a
month on that not bad yeah
not bad yeah so you put two and a half
thousand pounds down yeah and then
you're making 650 a month
yeah right yeah and i had the cost of
the uh hmo works which is about 2008
okay yeah so it's about five brand all
in
uh amiibo money back um so yeah that's
great i mean i usually say with rental
rents you're making a minimum 500 pounds
yeah and you want to make sure that
you're making a 100 roi which you are
yeah so that was a cracking little house
yeah um however that small fish compared
to some of the other stuff that you've
been working on yeah in fact
your deal after that was a little bit
bigger than that wasn't it
yeah so after that one um i kind of
basically all the properties that i look
to do i'm like specialized in a specific
type of rent to rent so i work with
social housing providers what is social
housing providers
so social housing so what we do is we
work with people who are temporarily
homeless
or they're slightly vulnerable they
could have been through like domestic
abuse and stuff like that
those type of people don't always go
directly to the council and these things
called housing associations and
registered social landlords yeah and so
they get referred to these schemes and
it's their job to either have their own
properties which they then put into
or some of them work on like a lease
scheme basis
so they'll work with private landlords
to lease their properties for a
guaranteed rent
yeah and they'll then place these
tenants into those properties yeah so
that's how that model works
uh very niche very very niche not loads
of people know about it
no um and and you've really studied this
yeah and and i mean what what is it
about social housing that you love is it
is it just the money
is there giving back parts to it what's
to talk to me through yeah i mean you
know i've got
i've got some of my houses in the exact
same way yeah and for me
i think it's it's not only is it is it
financially it can make sense but it's
also quite
a rewarding thing to do absolutely i
mean i could make more money if i was
letting out to professionals
i could make more money if i was letting
out students i am making a slightly
smaller margin from doing social housing
supported living on a rent-to-rent basis
however it's the fact that you you know
you're really helping people in the
community yeah there's people who really
need houses like
huge lists especially in birmingham as
well and london as well
and there's huge lists of people that
require housing
and some of them are still in like like
really horrible
like dingy hotels like you know they had
to get like sort of food vouchers
don't have any cooking facilities and
stuff like that so for me
yeah it's great that i'm making money at
the same time but i'm also helping
someone move from somewhere but perhaps
they're kind of forced to live to
somewhere they can choose okay this is a
really nice house
like most of the places i take on have
been recently refurbished yeah
so like this place new carpets new pain
all that sort of good stuff so when
these people move in
to them it's like paradise exactly yeah
yeah i think that's so rewarding
um so this the second deal and i always
say you've probably heard me say this
start small but every time every time
you do another deal make sure it's
bigger you just gotta go bigger and
bigger yeah you took that to heart right
yeah actually i took that to the next
level yeah tell me tell me the figures
of the second deal
so once again uh working with the
sourcing agent that had on board ronaldo
um what we did was i kind of said to him
look i've got a huge need as i mentioned
like with social housing supported
living the tenant lists
huge um so i've kind of got like an
unlimited need for properties like you
bring me a property i'm gonna take it on
the great thing is as well is because i
had investors on board even if i ran out
of my own funds
which at this point i didn't have a lot
of um you know i could get someone else
to back the deal
um so then we moved on to looking at
other areas so
bradford is another area which is great
for social housing support accommodation
we managed to come across a investor who
owned a block
of 38 apartments and they're all studios
and this was like like the next step up
for me i was like well i'm going from
like single units to like blocks now
a 38 block yeah student apartment
yeah yeah and you took it on on a rent
around yeah so what we did was we spoke
with the landlord
um and like half of it was let out for
students and half of it was like used a
serviced accommodation
but he was like kind of running the
operations and he's quite an odd chap as
well so like he was like just a really
tired landlord
um and i managed to get in contact with
him through the sourcing agent had a
little conversation
about social housing supported living
how it all works um
and he was like well if it's all hands
off for me because i'm going to be doing
all the work instead of hitting yeah
he's happy to take a slightly lower
return
and just sit back and relax and like
almost practically retire
um so i gave a guaranteed rent off of
the back of it and i'll be honest the
profit margins weren't huge because they
were studio flats
however that deal in total per month was
making me 1900
pounds per month and that's pretty
passive right yeah it was passive so the
thing is for me it was just getting the
deal set
up and the contracts written stuff in
place once the social housing
all the supported living providers in
place they kind of have their own like
in-house management team and stuff so
everything's processed
so you sign the agreement yeah they're
making 1900 a month
yeah passive income and then end up
selling it
and then you're gonna sell it yeah crazy
yeah
why did you sell it i know you was kind
of forced to sell it a little bit
yeah but but and it ended up being very
profitable yeah so talk me through what
happened for me bradford is still quite
far i'm based in derby whereas like
birmingham where i've got my first
property on board it's quite local it's
not far for me to travel
um so every now and then within my
business what i do is even if i do work
with landlords i still go and check on
the properties just like an estate agent
organizing agent would
and i kind of thought i don't really
want to have to go up there every now
and then to go check on the properties
luckily the housing association that i
was working with they were interested in
also purchasing properties in land
so they actually had a discussion with
me about purchasing the property
and i was quite fortunate in the
agreement that i had to have kind of
like first right to refusal
if the owner was to sell so hang on the
owner wants to sell
but you've got an agreement that says
that you've got the right to refuse them
selling it yeah
but you thought actually if they pay me
a decent chunk of money yeah
it means then i've got some i've got
some cash yeah and i'll
sacrifice my 1900 pounds to have that
chunk of cash
yeah kind of right yeah so like a lot of
people might think
oh well you could have had a long-term
income from it yeah i mean i've got to
say i
was going through my head yeah exactly
but for me at the same time
i wasn't just thinking i've got 38 units
and this is the end of it for me now i
had quite a big goal i want to build
like a really really
big property portfolio yeah and for me
the long-term goal is actually to own
assets as well
um so i can't disclose the amount but i
got yeah why not
tell me the amount how much no i know
you guys i signed an nda with him
but it was enough to put into your next
deal yeah which is
even bigger yeah dude you're an animal
go on what's this next deal yes it just
keeps snowballing so
obviously i went from you know one
property to then 38 and now
this is once again working with a
sourcing agent which has been absolutely
amazing for me
um but once again we managed to source
another block
instead of just one block it's three
blocks um
over the three blocks it's 184 units in
total and these are student
accommodations so this is like
a huge huge deal that's not no money
down deal though right you haven't put
some money down so i'm having to put
some money down how much um
so in total it's going to cost me about
between 20 to 30k
and i've got to like change over
mattresses and stuff like that you're
going to use the money that you got from
the that's the beauty of it
yeah so when i started off with this
strategy as i mentioned like i literally
just had five grand to put into the deal
and the money that i've got now has
obviously all come from this the selling
of the last deal that i had
yeah i'm really grateful that i took
that option because in all honesty i
probably wouldn't have the funds to do
this deal
right now yeah um yeah and you've still
got your 650 coming in a month from your
first rent
yeah yeah yeah still got that yeah
stupid guy cash flow coming in
um and now with this deal that i'm
taking on 184 units
we're just applying for planning
permission uh it should take anywhere
between eight to thirteen weeks yeah
um and we should at least at a bare
minimum be able to achieve like a two
year temporary change of use
um but best case scenario is we get it
repurposed from
you know student accommodation to
supported living yeah and
when that deal kicks in i'll be getting
approximately about 30 000 pounds a
month
that's great yeah yeah you haven't got
the keys yet though i have actually got
the keys
oh yeah the keys i always say never be
at ease until you've got the keys
yeah i've got the keys that's good yeah
so incredible incredible deal
and let's see how it pans out i'm sure
by the sounds of things it's going to
pan out really really well
what would you say the risks are though
to people i mean
rent to rents potentially a bit risky
yeah buying from deal sources is also
risque yeah
doing big deals is risky
do you feel that there's a lot of risk
to this strategy or
where are we out there there is risk but
it's down to you to kind of work your
way around those risks so for example
when i got into this i knew that
although i am getting a guaranteed rent
from the housing provider there are
things that go wrong with the property
one thing that did actually happen with
the property that i've still got on
board the one where i'm in the 650 a
month
is we had a pipe burst in the property
so temporarily
i have actually had to kind of stop the
rental and that property to get things
in
sorted so for a month for that period
until everything was sorted
i wasn't in any earning any income from
it had i taken out all the money
from my business and spent it i wouldn't
be able to pay the rent to the landlord
yeah so it was kind of having that plan
in place at the beginning knowing that
things can go wrong
and instead of taking all the money out
keeping it within the business
are you planning on investing as well
building up your own portfolio
yeah from the profits of the rent to
rent yeah so with this student
accommodation deal obviously i'm going
to get quite a sizeable amount out of it
my goal is not to then go and waste all
that money um
that 30 40 however much i'm going to be
getting per calendar month
is all going to go straight back into
purchasing properties every single month
my goal is to
purchasing the new property and working
with investors as well and how old how
old are you 24
24 yeah fantastic i mean you do really
well 24
and i think that i mean how we kind of
got pro i know you've been watching me
on youtube for a couple years and doing
online videos and stuff
but you invited me to go on your podcast
yeah
and um amelia my talent manager got the
got the
inquiry looked into it she rings me up
she goes samuel there's a guy called
uh raja and he's asked if you can go on
his podcast
okay she says i've gone on his website
and stuff
he's doing crazy things with rent to
rents and he also
on his website credit's you yeah it says
i know everything i learned from samuel
leeds yeah check him out
and she's like so i reckon you should go
on his podcast but i also reckon
you should get him on winners wednesday
yeah yeah so what made you agree to come
on windows on a wednesday
so obviously um you know like you
mentioned i've been watching your videos
for a couple of years so literally
everything that i've learned over the
years has just been watching your videos
um i've not had any like you know
mentorship from any other like trainer
or anyone else like that
everything i've learned has come from
your videos amazing man
wow it just shows the power of of
youtube yeah
exactly yeah and i mean i believe in
paid training i think i think
i encourage people to do paid training
um but i
i guess it just shows that the content
that we put out there
it really does work yeah and i think
like even with me just watching the
youtube videos
as you mentioned with the paid training
i think if i did come on board with a
class instead of
listening to people around me saying you
know don't do it i could have been
successful a lot earlier
yeah yeah for sure and i'm sure you will
still do some paid training with us at
some point because hey
it's it's the free stuff's paid off but
uh no it's incredible and on wednesday's
wednesday we have a real diverse you
know different people from
different different types of training in
that so um people want to check you out
you check out your podcast what's it
called and how can they check out the
podcast yeah so the podcast name is real
estate with roger
um i'll send you across the link so
people can just click on yeah
the description and you'll be able to
head on there but if you want to contact
me or anything like that at all you can
find me on instagram
at raj instagram um but yeah it's
probably the best way to contact me
incredible that's great well i'll i'll
definitely be subscribing
and i'll be uh i'll be i'll be tuning
into the podcast what advice would you
give to someone
starting out maybe they're young what
are you still at university by the way
accounting and finance
oh interesting okay so so someone
starting out
maybe young just finished university
they want to go into property yeah
what would your advice be first steps to
start
number one i think the most important
thing is actually saving your money
that's something i didn't do at the
start and
it's probably the reason why i got
started a lot later actually and didn't
pay for any like paid training uh so
number one they'd definitely save
um you know have you know at least five
or six months worth of savings compared
to how much you usually earn
and on top of that actually go out there
and do it
i think that's the most important thing
a lot of people will read
or even watch the youtube videos maybe
even come to the crash course
but then not go not go and do anything
after that yeah um so you've got to take
action
uh as i mentioned to you earlier i spoke
with a chap called jay who's also being
on the winners on a wednesday he's one
of the sources i've been passing this
year
exactly yeah yeah he's a good guy yeah
and he's one of those people where
i hadn't met him before um like not too
long ago it's only been like a couple of
weeks since i met him and he's bought me
so many properties but he's one of those
guys and these are the type of people
that you need to have around you
yeah that are just out there and they're
just doing deals after deals after deals
yeah
he did pay for the trainer yeah maybe if
you'd have paid for the training you
wouldn't have to pay him to find the
deal probably not
but hey you're taking massive action
yeah and uh it's really good to see so
i'm rooting for you
and um great so final piece of advice
for somebody that needs that that that
kick up the bun motivation or that
golden nugget
go just go out there and do it um you
know there's no other way
of you achieving success without going
out and implementing it
um once you've got that knowledge
whether it's paid training whether it's
reading books whatever it is obviously
you've got
you've got a book yourself haven't you
buy it yeah yeah
um you know go out there get the
knowledge and just implement it
i mean i'm not exactly you know 34 years
old i'm not a seasoned investor or
anything like that i've started off
fairly newly this
year here but i've gone out there and
i've made the effort and without that i
wouldn't you know get 184 units come out
of nowhere
absolutely and i think as well when
you're stepping out big like you
expect people to try and protect you and
tell you not to do it yeah
you know because that's what have you
heard people saying like don't do it
yeah be careful yeah
yeah i mean in all honesty i didn't get
a great reception from my family to
start off with they didn't quite
understand the concept of like rent to
rent
um so i think educating the people that
are around you as well
is an important part of it people will
tell you not to go and do the deals not
to attend the training not to because
they love you and they're trying to
protect you and keep you safe yeah but
actually
you don't necessarily need that exactly
yeah you know you need that when you're
a baby
yeah but when you're a grown man yeah
sometimes you just say actually mom i
love you
but i'm gonna get around some
millionaires yeah they're gonna drag me
over the finish line
so hey it's been a real pleasure
chatting with you buddy and um honestly
massive massive respect for me so
congrats
i look forward to seeing what happens
with your next big deal yeah guys i hope
you enjoyed that i think you'll agree is
a top top
guy please do me a massive favor smash
the like button and
turn on the notification subscribe bell
below
if you want to see a whole bunch more
every single week i interview someone
that's killing it in property
as a result of my training whether it be
free training paid for training
but you can check out a whole list up
here there's over 100 people
that have had their finances
revolutionized
through property also you can subscribe
right here
thanks so much for watching i'll see you
next time
[Music]
you